now powerful earthquake has hit Albania
the Defense Ministry reports that at
least six people have died the 6.4
magnitude quake struck just north of the
capital Tirana
a number of aftershocks have been felt
and the authorities have called on
people to stay outside we can now speak
to Besser lik Mehta who's a journalist
and editor of BIR in Albania that's a
Balkan investigative reporting network
thanks for talking to us
give us an idea then of how extensive
the damage is well the damage is quite
extensive across central Albania a major
emergency crews are still digging with
their hands and with heavy equipment in
the village of Samana close to the
epicenter where two building collapsed
also in the portal town of portal city
of Dewar's there there is another
collapse building and they are still
looking for survivors out there and what
sort of area has been most significantly
affected is it a densely populated area
or because it's some way out of the
capital is it more sparsely populated it
is a very densely populated area the
triangle between the city of Deraa
and Tirana it's the most populated area
of Albania where one-third of the
population this so the all this area has
been affected and the earthquake has
been felt as far as the Serbian city of
Novi Sad all across the region and the
Balkans I mean it's sad to say but often
in the early stages of a an earthquake
the casualty figures are quite low and
they steadily rise do you expect the
death toll to rise in this instance
unfortunately with with the collapse
buildings and the work with the
emergency crews still ongoing the fears
that the the casualty figures will rise
but people are still hoping for miracles
and the work is continued to to save as
many people as possible now it wasn't
that long ago was it that Albania had
another earthquake smaller than this one
it was in September it that suggests
therefore that there is a level of
preparedness amongst the authorities
would you agree
exactly I mean the reaction of the
emergency crews that we saw in the
Capitol today but also in the coastal
town of Duras was much higher and much
more preparedness compared to the
earthquake in September so this may help
in a sense aid to the rescue considering
that this earthquake is more significant
that the one in September and what sort
of happened what happens to communities
when there is a an earthquake like this
and obviously this one is is more
powerful than the last one in September
but what what the communities do do they
gather together do they heed the advice
and stay out of buildings where do they
go
the first response Hispanic and
everybody came out of the buildings in
their capital Tirana where I sit and
people stayed outside spending the night
the early let's say the early morning or
late night because the earthquake he
could five o'clock in in bars so they
could escape the aftershocks and but
also come together and relieve a little
bit distress there has been response by
the authorities there's been calls to
stay outside the schools have been
closed and there is also messages of so
their solidarity being sent out by
laypeople but also by the heads of state
basilique Mehta thank you very much
indeed for bringing us right up to speed
with the situation in Albania today
Thanks